la russie a le droit de protéger sa
sécurité les mots de vladimir poutine au
lendemain de son entretien avec son
homologue américain joe biden un sommet
virtuel à de deux heures au cours duquel
les deux hommes sont revenus sur la
situation en ukraine source de vives
tensions lowe président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky salue ce mercredi des
discussions positives même si chacun est
resté campé sur ses positions ou
washington menace ainsi moscou de fortes
sanctions en cas d' escalade militaire
on retrouve en russie notre
correspondante un éclaireur
bonjour antoine moscou demande de son
côté des garanties contre l'expansion de
l'otan en direction de ses frontières
oui tout à fait lors d'une conférence de
presse en présence du premier ministre
grec le président russe est revenu sur
ce sommet virtuel de la veille avec joe
biden plénière poutine a déclaré que la
russie ne pouvait pas ne pas ignorer
l'élargissement de l'otan à ses
frontières et que cette problématique
représentait l'une des plus grandes
menaces stratégiques pour son pays il a
également souligné que l'alliance
atlantique était un bloc militaire qui
poursuivait une logique de confrontation
avec la russie en conséquence moscou se
réservent simplement le droit d'assurer
sa sécurité écoutez
la russie mène une politique étrangère
pacifique mais elle a le droit d'assurer
sa sécurité comme je les dis à moyen et
à plus long terme il nous en discutons
avec nos partenaires avec tous nos
partenaires y compris mon interlocuteur
dit hier le président des états unis
monsieur baden nous ne pouvons pas ne
pas être préoccupées par la perspective
d'une éventuelle admission de l'ukraine
à l'otan car cela sans aucun doute
entraînera que des contingents
militaires de cette structure des bases
et des armures qui présente pour nous
une menace ils seront déployés
et au gras je suis un homme allongé
de façon plus concrète vladmir poutine a
fait savoir que les autorités russes
allaient transmettre la semaine
prochaine toute une série de mesures de
propositions sécuritaires à la partie
américaine le président russe a au
passage qualifié son entretien avec son
homologue américain d'ouvert et de
positif est le plus important sans doute
c'est que les deux hommes comptent
poursuivre ce dialogue le porte-parole
du kremlin en effet dit plus tôt dans la
journée que si les groupes de travail
russo américain parvenus à des résultats
tangibles les deux présidents pourraient
de nouveau s'entretenir
merci beaucoup antoine clairon en direct
de russie chez paris averti